Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Wildlife Survivor
Now, this is a different type of horror game and an interesting concept
You, or should I say, I,
am an adorable little bunbun that's escaped from a pack of wolves in the middle of the woods
The only way to get home is to survive the night as a helpless little bunbun
'You've successfully run away from a pack of wolves.'
That's what I just said.
'You're alone, hungry and thirsty.'
'You must find food and water'
'Rescue the other bunnies.'
So let us go,
And hopefully we'll find... OOOH
*nomming sounds*
YAYY!!
I ATE. LITTLE BU-
OHH
Little bunniplier already scared
Oh
It's a different perspective being an adorable little bunny
As adorable as I know I am
Ohh
This is so weird!
OH, HI!
IS THAT A WOLFY WOO?
Should I run away?
OHHHH IT WAS COMING THIS WAY
OOOOOOH IT WAS COMING THIS WAY
blap blap blap blap blah SO WAH WAH
OOOHH
I, I think I drank the whole lake DRY.
Oh man this is a thirsty bunbun
Ohh bunbun gonna go into the woods
It's such a different perspective and this is exactly what I was hoping for
It's the... slightly new experience
Little bunniplier, coming through the woods
Trying to find more bunnies to make more baby bunnies
I don't know why that's my first priority, but you know,
My head's on straight, so I know what I'm doing, I know what I'm about
It seems that I might have avoided the wolfy
Oh man, did I just go into a chasm of doom?
oooHEEYYYY
WHOOOOOOO
HEEEEEEEY
WOOOOOOOOOW
OH GOD
UUUUUH
I backed myself into a corner
I AM like a wild animal because I AM A WILD ANIMAL
HHHH YOU WOULDN'T LIKE ME WHEN I'M ANGRY
[Soft beeping]
WHAT'S THE BEEPING
WHAT'S THE BEEPING MEAN?
WHAT'S THAT MEAN
IS THAT A BOMB?
AM I A BOMB BUNNY?
Oh geez
OOH GEEZ
OH GOD
DOES THIS MEAN I'M THAT DESPERATELY HUNGRY I START BEEPING?
maybe I'm thirsty
Oh god, where am I going?
OH GEEZ, I NEED WA WA
BUNBUN NEEDS WAWA
OOOH SO BADLY
OH GEEZ
imma die aren't i
AHHHH
I'M DEAD??
LITTLE BUNNY JUST FLOPPED OVER DEAD
NOONE EVEN SHED A TEAR FOR THE POOR DEAD BUNBUN
I didn't even get eaten NOBODY WANTED MY CORPSE AFTER I WAS DEAD
fucking bullshit
Ah, so after reading the instructions I have discovered that I was thirsty
So I need to... I was getting plenty of food
lots of noms for the little bunbun but
I need...
That's a wolfy
So
eh
Slurpity slurp
Slurpity
THEE WE GO THAT'S SLURPIN DOWN INTO MY GUT
So there's a wo-- ooohhh
Oh no that's a rock
Ha, mysterious how that rock looked exactly like a wolfy woo
Kay, we get one more drink
UEAHH
Uuh
Okay, so  I was actually right near another bun bun before I keeled over from thirst.
That must have been a weird experience for that other bun
Just to see a fellow bun bun friend, and then have them immediately die.
Is that in front of me?
uuh
AHHHHH OOOOOOOOHHHH NELLLYYY
Okay, I think we're okay.
*nom nom*
eeeauuhh eaauuhhh! eat eat eat eat eat eat!
eat lIttle bunny, eat little bunny!
Okay, I don't know where I am now
I think I'm lost from uuh, from the other bun that I was going to find
uh oh
What was that?
Was that the tired?
Ok
So I think that was the chasm that I entered, and I believe I made a right turn somewhere here
Oh no, I'm so tired
Ok
So if I hit a dead end, I'll-
Ok, this is the dead end
So it's just to the right, here
Little bunny
Little bunny Fuu fuu
Running through the forest
Holy shit I'm gonna die!
Uuh I'm tired
OK
Ahhh!
Bunny!
Make babies with me!
Ooohh!
I saved a bunny
Ok that's good!
Ok I saved a bunny
*nom nom nom*
So the super jump, I can jump out of this chasm
heBLEph
Oh that didn't-
That's not as super as I thought it was gonna be...
Yeee
Yeeee
Oh jeez
Oh geez
That's not where I wanted to be
Little bunny is going in a circle
Someone save bunniplier!
Please!
I'm alone!
and scared...
Uuuuhhhh
[Growling]
AHHHH! OK!
[Intense chase music]
Aaaaeeeeyyy
Ooooh!
Runnin' runnin' runnin' through the woods
Oh god!
That is some intense music
Holy shit!
Eeeehhhh
It's right behind me!
Aaaah another one!!
Oooh god!
Oh god oh god oh god oh god
Is that a bunny?
No that's a ROCK
Aaaggghhh shit!
I'm dead
Oh god oh god oh goddd
Ok
I think we're ok
But I think I'm about to die of thirst
Oh that runnin' made me a thirsty bunbun
[Beeping]
Bunniplier need some water after having a near brush with DEATH.
Okay
Where's Wa-wa?
Come on, give me my wa-wa! Please!
I'm desperate!
Oh god!
Oh no!
Oh, I'm gonna die again.
[Beeping getting louder]
I'm gonna die of thirst because I'm a failure
Aaaaaaaaaghhhh
Shit.
Those are gonna be my last words when I actually die
'Aaaaaaaaaghhhh shit!'
And then I'm dead.
It's not funny!
It's not a joke!
*Fails to contain laughter*
Alright, let me give this another go
This time-
Okay, so I have a better idea
I-I I think there's probably only one water source?
And uh
It's probably only this one
So I need to return here
Often
And then
Save my running juice
For quickly getting there and back
Hey, there you are!
Ok
So get you
Save 'em
Yeeeaaah
Alright
We're going to have a beautiful family once we get outta here and
go to vacation in Maui
Aaaahh
But for now we're gonna run for our goddamn life
Where's that ding dong dang
WA-WAAA
Where's the wa-wa?!
Heeeyy
Ok- Oooh there it is
Uuuh
*Glugging*
Little bunny drinking
Taking sips with my little...
Schhh- ...nuffler
Whatever- What is it called?
Fuck I don't know!
The- the-
The bunny nose
Bullshit
Piece of shit
Sniffer
Bitch!
That's the technical term for it!
Found another wa-wa!
That's not important right now!
Tryin' to-
Figure the-
Fucking
What's the fucking name of the rabbit's nose-mouth?
The whole thing!
I don't know!
Fuck it!
Who cares?!
Not important!
Bunniplier doesn't need to know!
Bunniplier is the best bunny!
Bunniplier don't need to know-known
Is that a bunny?!!
Helloowww!
You wanna be ma-
Wife?
Hello.
Ok, so apparently the first way that I went was the only way that there wasn't any more water
so I fubbernucked my own self
Uh oh.
Uh oh!
Uh ooh!
Uh ooh!!
Uh ooh!!!
Uh ooh!!!!
Ooooohh!
Heeyyy!
Oooh!
Let's go!
Away!
Forever!
God damn it!
How am I supposed to be able to find anymore bunbuns?
There's four more!
How am I suppose to be able to find four more buns?
You can barely see anything in these woods
And how are THEY surviving?
BUUUUUN
I found you!
Oooh I got three!
I'm not gonna get all six!
There's no way in hell!
There's no way in goddamn hell
What is this?
Can I light a fire?
Bunniplier needs warmth!
Bunniplier needs to seduce all the lady bunnies if you know what I mean
Oooh! Hello river!
Okay!
So Bunniplier found a river
What does that mean for bunbun?
*Glugging*
Also, is this supposed to be snow?
I didn't even connect the dots that this might actually be snow
Any bunbuns over there?
Any bunbuns?
Euuuuugh!
Can I super jump across this?
Ah buuuuhhh!
That was a nice jump
That was a quality yump!
If I need to run away from any-
ne'er-do-wells, I know how to do it.
Yumpin'.
And what, pray tell, is thi-
Aaaah! Aaoooh
Fuuuck me-eh-eh-eh-eh!
Ooo-kay
AaaAAAaah
That's not a good sound!
I am dead.
I'm dead
I'm dead!
Ooooh!
Aaaah bunbun!
Four!
Four!!
I got four!
Oooh!
Why didn't you go after thaaa-
[Growling]
-aat bunbun instead of me?
Oooooohhh NELLY!
Super jump!
AHHHH!
OH FUCK!
Oh jee-
Oh, god damnit.
Ooooh man, that was terrifying!
That was terrifying!
That was horrifying! A little bunniplier's heart can't take that!
Heart's beatin' over 200 beats per minute!
It's deadly for a little bunbun to be that mean...
Ok
So that-
is-
What was the name of this game? Like-
Wildlife Survivor, so-
I got four of six bunnies
which is way better than I thought that I would ever do
and that game is shockingly scary because
It puts you in the perspective of something that is actually helpless
Not just a guy who can't fight back a monster
You're a bunny
A little itty bitty bunny
And you're little itty bitty bunny self is gonna get its ass
Bit off
By the wolves
And the cold
And the nature.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
You can try this game for yourself down in the description below
Let me know if ya
Get all six and-
Let me know if there is a special ending to play
So thanks again!
And as always...
I will see you,
In the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Haunted by Shurk]